The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HUGH MCMANUS: This
video is intended
to describe some of the key
features of the Lean Enterprise
Value Lean Healthcare
Clinic Simulation.
A video can't substitute for
the experience of attending
an intense learning
simulation such as this one,
and we won't attempt to do that.
Instead, what we're
going to do is
describe what the students
experience during the day,
cover at least some of the
lessons of what they learn,
and for those of you that are
interested in simulation-based
education, describe some of
the features of the learning
simulation.
The simulation
itself and this video
are broken into three
pieces, three modules.
One is the learning of
the simulation itself.
It's accompanied by some
background information
in how Lean applies to health
care and some simple tools
for getting local
processes under control.
The second is a
structured improvement
using Value Stream Mapping,
Capacity Calculation,
and a Planned Improvement Method
to improve the local processes
at each clinic to make
them at least functional.
And the third attacks problems
that cannot be handled
at the individual clinics.
And in this exercise, the
entire group of students
participates in a simulated
Rapid Process Improvement
Workshop where they break
down into functional teams
and do a complete reengineering
of the clinic process
across the whole room with
cooperation between clinics
in order to solve
some problems that
are unsolvable at
the local level,
and also create a overall
very high-performing clinic
environment.
Basically, what you are
in our simulated world
is a group of
outpatient clinics.
We have an old process
that is not very good.
There's high variation in
workload in the processes.
The overall performance
is pretty poor.
We're going to actually
let you experience that.
You're going to play with it.
Maybe for a little while you'll
be learning how to do it.
But it's not that complicated.
You should be able to learn
your own jobs pretty quickly.
But then you will
find that it still
doesn't work very well because
the system itself is set up
not very well.
At that point, the simulation,
once you've learned it,
becomes a practice field for
applying Lean techniques.
What can we do to make
this process better?
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to have
basically three segments.
The segments will have one
or two rounds of play each.
We're going to first
learn the simulation.
That's what we're
doing right now.
We're going to apply Lean
locally at each of your tables.
You will strategize and
apply some Lean interventions
to make your individual
clinic work better.
And then we're going to
do another round where
we start thinking about, well,
there's only so much one can
do locally.
What are some of
the things that we
can do by coordinating
across our whole health care
enterprise by expanding our
vision of the value stream
beyond just the one clinic so
that the whole room can work
together to make a more
efficient system that,
for example, shares resources
or redirects patients to places
that are better able
to take care of them.
What we're gonna do in this
module is first of all,
just learn how to play the
simulation because the idea
that we would like you to
get is to think about this
as a process that mirrors--
perhaps does not exactly
simulate-- but mirrors
the kind of process that
you'd see in a clinic or ER
where a patient is flowing
through the system.
And we're trying to
get that patient value
stream to be lean.
So we're gonna learn
the simulation.
We're going to experience the
frustrations of a not very
good process and
apply a couple simple
Lean tools to try to get
it to at least perform
at a minimum level.
Key thing right now, though,
is to kind of wrap your brain
around the Sim so
that we can stop
thinking about it, because later
in the day, what we would like
to do is think about
this as a process
and apply Lean tools
and analyses to it so
that the game, as it were, sort
of fades into the background,
and we worry more about
the realities of the tools
and using them to improve
the process that's
embodied in the simulation.
The rules are very
straightforward.
And in fact, they are
pretty much in front of you.
If everyone has a mat in front
of them that says Process,
and if you just read that
and execute those actions
faithfully, you'll be fine.
It's important that you
do that because that's
the basis for
future improvements.
If you don't
understand the process,
it's going to be
difficult to improve it.
So Round 1.
And the minute is the time.
You will now be
referring to this
rather than making
those times up.
You have 12 minutes
to get things done.
If you are not
done in 12 minutes,
you can no longer
process, you can no longer
register any new patients.
But you have 3
minutes of overtime
to finish the existing patients.
And I will reset the
clock at that time,
and then we'll count
up to 3 minutes.
So ready and go.
This montage will illustrate
some of the features
of the simulation.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's a long one.
HUGH MCMANUS: The simulation
involves the processing
of little LEGO
people, LEGO patients,
through a simulated clinic
with various functions
such as registration, triage,
examination, diagnosis,
and discharge.
The simulation has a
fair amount of paperwork.
A lot of it is a
little frustrating,
a little bit redundant.
Some of it is
unnecessarily complicated,
although the paperwork does
have important information that
affects the flow of the
patients and their treatment.
Timers are used to represent
the capacity of the system
so it doesn't turn into a
race to get things done,
although physical dexterity
is sometimes required.
There are a lot of manual steps.
But the basic processes are
represented by the timers.
And those are ultimately
the constraints
on the system that allows the
students to focus ultimately
on the process itself
rather than the details.
The variation in the
system is represented
a couple of different ways.
One is by the patient himself.
The little LEGO patient has
different colors of head,
body, and legs that
affect the diagnosis.
This is the "each patient
is different" phenomena.
The actual process
variation is represented
by dice that create a
unpredictable source
of variation in each station.
And these can
affect both the time
it takes to process
the individual patient
and in some cases, in
the case of diagnosis,
the dice can indicate whether
a test is failed or passed,
or whether the machine
fails to perform
and the test has
to be done over.
AUDIENCE: There's a
patient number at the top--
HUGH MCMANUS: The
patients sometimes
have to leave the table and
go to a little LEGO hospital.
AUDIENCE: I'll be back.
HUGH MCMANUS: So there are some
externalities to the system.
Sometimes the clinic cannot
handle a given patient.
There are other
times when patients
don't have to go
to the hospital,
but nevertheless due to
lack of either capacity
or the correct equipment, they
can't be treated at the clinic,
and therefore, the
clinic effectively
fails to treat the patient.
These are things
that are eventually
dealt with in the last
round of the simulation.
As the first round or
two go on, the students
do learn to master
their own processes.
But it still remains a
little bit confusing.
The process is not
a very good one.
And so but the students get past
the simulation rules and start
thinking about what is
wrong with this process.
What's the overall flow?
And what is the purpose
of the paperwork?
And what are the
sources of variation?
And how can we make
this process better?
OK.
Regular time is done.
We are starting
overtime, 3 minutes.
No new patients
may be registered.
The simulation uses
overtime basically
to clear patients off the
table so that it's not
a continuing state simulation.
AUDIENCE: It failed test.
Yellow timer.
AUDIENCE: This is
like the blindfold
where everybody [INAUDIBLE].
HUGH MCMANUS:
Basically, the clinic
closes down for the night.
This allows a completion of
the metrics for each day--
OK.
So if there's any patients
still out on the floor,
they're going to be
recorded as untreated.
--and also makes it simpler
to execute the simulation.
You don't have patients
that are mysteriously
trapped in the clinic overnight.
Unfinished patients and
any unfinished paperwork
to that person to just put away.
That would be good.
We're going to clear the table.
And what we'd like you to do
is put patients and errors.
That's untreated patients,
not-- hospital's OK.
But untreated
patients or patients
that were treated incorrectly.
We can use visual control.
Anybody who's been in a
hospital has seen these kind
of scheduling boards.
Students now use visual
controls and intuitive small
improvements in standardizations
in their process
to make it perform a
little bit better at least,
to make it perform not
quite so chaotically.
All righty.
Round 2.
Go.
And try the process again.
Typically, improvements
are noticeable but small.
And at the end of
this process, students
are encouraged to share their
various ideas with the larger
group.
Let's total up our
statistics, put them up.
So that they can take
some ownership of it.
So that the larger group
can see the variety
of different improvement
ideas that people
can come up with just
sort of creatively
in the first
improvement attempt.
AUDIENCE: Pretend it
was width to width.
HUGH MCMANUS: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We did the same thing.
And we actually
used sticky labels.
AUDIENCE: We did the
similar kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: MV, lab, triage.
HUGH MCMANUS: Yeah.
So great.
In the second module of
the simulation experience,
the students receive
some lecture material
and then embark on
a major exercise.
The process is analyzed
using value stream mapping,
some gemba visits where people
look at how the process work
in detail on the table.
And also, they do
some analysis by using
capacity calculations
and other calculations
to try to understand the
capacity and other features
of the simulation
quantitatively.
They then go through a
structured improvement process
where ideas are brainstormed,
costs are figured out,
and an improvement
approach is agreed upon.
OK.
It is Round 3.
Let's go.
These improvements are
done at the single table
level, the single clinic level.
AUDIENCE: So Tom,
the next patient--
AUDIENCE: Registration.
We have a new patient.
AUDIENCE: Can you take that
patient to registration, Tom?
HUGH MCMANUS: No interaction
between the clinics
is done at this time.
So the attempt is to locally
optimize the process.
With the new process, the
tables are quieter, calmer.
The work seems to be
proceeding in a little bit more
of an organized way.
AUDIENCE: Lab, don't
forget your end time.
You're gonna put you end time--
HUGH MCMANUS: There's
even time for the students
to improve their process
and organize their workspace
while the work is going on.
AUDIENCE: Who's doing
discharge for me?
Nobody?
Clogged on discharge.
HUGH MCMANUS: The
result is almost always
better performance.
AUDIENCE: This is so fun.
HUGH MCMANUS: All right.
That's it.
Although there is significant
variation by table,
not every clinic
shows improvement
in their process based on the
ideas that they implemented.
Successfully treated?
So six here, three there.
Let's go, guys.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
So we had the problem at
the doctor getting worse.
And that was an external
condition, right?
You just got more gray patients.
Right?
You guys kind of had
bad luck, more bad roles
on the diagnostics.
You folks, things clicked.
Right?
The process change worked.
Your luck was reasonable.
Things clicked.
All right.
Everybody ready?
Seems very quiet.
I think we're ready.
Let's go.
To stabilize the new process
and collect a little bit
more information
on its performance,
the simulation is run
again using a new process.
Typically, performance
is good or better
than the previous round.
However, the performance
varies by table, still.
And the students
observe that there's
high variation and factors
beyond their control, which
are still limiting their
performance to a level
lower than they would like.
Didn't ultimately have
success in this round.
They have identified
a shifted constraint.
These guys are definitely
getting better, and same thing.
Right?
Shift.
They've identified
the same problem.
You guys, everything
was going great.
Is there anything--
if I asked you to do
10, what would be the problem?
Oh, OK.
So it was a bottleneck at the
discharge at the end there.
OK.
AUDIENCE: We had a lot of
bad luck in our failed tests.
In failed tests.
OK.
Everybody had bad luck.
What does that tell you?
Yep.
It's the new normal.
Right.
So we're going to do a
mock RPW to make this work.
Here is our electronic records.
We don't have to do
the paperwork anymore.
That's good.
Let's set up some
cross-functional teams.
First of all, let's figure
out what our plan is.
OK.
And there's your team.
So go to it.
The challenge in the final
round of the simulation
is to succeed in only
one round of play.
There isn't a second round
to stabilize the new process.
This requires the students
to focus on the process.
It's designed to do
a good job, but it
must be executed
carefully and successfully
in order for the
students to have
good performance
in the first round
after implementing
a lot of changes.
Visual controls and constant
communication ensure success.
AUDIENCE: This
patient is our team.
Black.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Our team.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: This goes to--
to that side.
Thank you.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: 7 is back.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you.
7 is back.
7 is good.
7 is discharged.
AUDIENCE: 7 discharging.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
AUDIENCE: This one goes to you.
AUDIENCE: Here we go.
HUGH MCMANUS: Six minutes.
Halfway through.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
HUGH MCMANUS: Clock here.
We're going overtime.
Yeah.
The last patient is
winding their way
through the otherwise
empty clinic.
Right?
It's gone from being a mob scene
to being like, it's one person.
The thing that
worked really well
was the fact that you
had this simple system.
There was a lot of
yelling, but everyone
could see what was going on,
and everyone was communicating.
Like, it's they're finished!
They're finished!
Hello!
But the information
got transferred.
I thought that was key.
And the other thing is
the diagnostician team
did a super job of
both figuring out
how to optimize that system--
good job, diagnosticians.
Our final discussion
highlights what
works about the new
process and also
in the spirit of
continuous improvement,
mentions what could be
improved if the simulation was
to keep going.
AUDIENCE: The context
of a [INAUDIBLE] OPIW.
This is what would
happen in a week.
You would get to
the end of the week
with your new system tested.
It's not yet ready for
full scale implementation.
You're going to have to refine
it, get the training ready--
HUGH MCMANUS: It's probably
going to be pretty ragged.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But at
the end of the week,
you would have gotten a whole
new system developed and tested
to this stage.
And that's what you did.
So that's what we're
doing at the moment.
HUGH MCMANUS: It's about
this frantic for a week.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
That is why you need to
test your implementation.
This way we're
spending half a year
planning the perfect solution.
It does not work because you
can't anticipate those things.
So you launch, you look at what
doesn't work, and you fix it.
You relaunch.
And that's how you just
run through the cycles.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] cycles.
GUEST SPEAKER: Forget your
health care upbringing with,
let's study this for half
a year or a full year.
Let's spend another half a year
designing the perfect solution
and then evaluate
after another year.
That's not a good
way of doing it.
Do it this way.